[Music]
on this Thursday night counting the
hours more hostages released from Gaza
as the US pushes to extend the pause in
fighting it's imperative that Israel act
in accordance with International
humanitarian law can it last as more
violence threatens The Fragile deal
assassination accusations the six
separatist in New York who says India
wants him dead we don't fear death here
in America where this leaves the invest
investigation into the murder of a
Canadian sick man the damning review
after a global news investigation we
have a right to breathe clean a we have
a right to uh feel safe in our homes the
effects of chemical plants and
refineries on an Ontario First Nation
and controversy reignited the Royal
Revelations pushing a Family Feud back
into the
spotlight global national with Donna
frez good evening and thanks for joining
us one more day that's where we're at in
the pause in fighting in Gaza and the
hostage release tonight a spokesperson
for the White House said us negotiators
are working hour by hour to try to get a
seventh day turned into an eighth and a
ninth and Beyond there is more good news
tonight six more hostages were freed
from Gaza late today they're on their
way back to their families earlier today
two other women were released from
captivity after 55 days in exchange 30
Palestinians detained in Israeli prisons
have been freed
tonight good
see will it continue while The American
Secretary of State hopes so Anthony
blinkin met both Israeli and Palestinian
leaders today he says the way Israel
defends itself
matters and I underscore the imperative
to the United States that the massive
loss of civilian life and displacement
of the scale that we saw in Northern
Gaza not be repeated in the South still
Israel's military says it is ready to
resume its war on Hamas at a moment's
notice Danielle Hamin has our top story
from Israel tonight and a warning some
of the images in it are
distressing it took 55 days for Karen
Shem to get this call her daughter Mia
she'd just been told was on her way
home the French Israeli hostage had
appeared in a video released by Hamas in
the days following her
abduction
Thursday night they were finally
reunited at a military base in
Israel for other families the anguish
has just reached a new level Hamas
released a hostage video of Yen
bibas he was abducted separately from
his wife Shiri and children
four-year-old arel and 10-month-old kir
she was last seen clutching her boys
when the militants stormed their kibuts
Hamas is claim they were killed in an
Israeli bombardment but provided no
proof in the video bibus accuses
Israel's primee minister of killing his
family Israel calls it psychological
warfare the day began with news the
temporary ceasefire had been extended
minutes before the 700 a.m.
deadline then 40 minutes later in
Jerusalem surveillance video shows the
moment a white car stops at a crowded
bus stop two men brothers get out and
open fire three people are killed six
are wounded the Palestinian men are then
gunned down by off-duty soldiers and a
civilian Hamas later claimed
responsibility Israel's farri national
security minister turned up at the scene
saying the attack shows the country can
only win by Waging War against
Hamas among the dead a pregnant school
teacher a principal and a 73-year-old
rabbi it comes a day after two
Palestinian boys were shot by Israeli
forces in the West Bank they were 8 and
15 years old the Israel Defense Forces
have said they are ready to resume
fighting in the Gaza Strip if the
ceasefire agreement with Hamas is not
renewed for another day but US Secretary
of State Anthony blinkin has made it
clear to Israel it has to put in place
protections for civilians and the
massive loss of life in Northern Gaza
cannot be repeated in the South Donna
Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem thanks the
Indian government has responded to
allegations by the US justice department
that an agent for the Indian government
attempted to assassinate a six
separatist on us soil it says such a
crime would be contrary to government
policy the murder for H plot is laid out
in a detailed indictment made public
yesterday in New York and it includes
links to the killing of a six separatist
in BC Mackenzie gray on how the Indian
government response to that allegation
differs from its response to
Canada thank you for joining us today a
new tone from India on assassination
allegations this is a matter of concern
we have said and let me reiterate that
this is also contrary to government
policy a consiliary statement responding
to to an American indictment alleging an
Indian national tried but failed to hire
a hitman to kill this man seek
separatist and Canada US dual National
gatan sing panu I'm going to continue my
campaign for kistan referendum and also
uh This is Home of the Brave and land of
the free we don't fear death here in
America but in Canada an assassination
attempt was successful Justin Trudeau
saying six separatist Hardeep sing nider
June murder outside of BC gwara was
carried out by agents of the Indian
government leading Delhi to take a
different tone than with the Americans
we have also seen interference by
Canadian diplomats in our Internal
Affairs we've said this from this uh
Podium and that is obviously
unacceptable the Indian government has
not agreed to investigate the nider
murder but will examine the foiled us
plot the government announced today that
it was uh conducting an investigation uh
and that's good and appropriate and we
look forward to seeing the
results the world sick or ganization
believes the US indictment proves a
Canadian policing failure to protect ner
but the former National Security adviser
to both Justin Trudeau and Steven Harper
believes that's a simplistic view it's
easy to say we Canada mucked up but if
you're not at the right place at the
right
time sometimes you just can't move
that's pretty damning evidence Canada's
former top spy feels that us indictment
and its references to the njer murder
will likely be the most information
Canadians will get on the case and my
suspicion is that the people who carried
out the attack are probably long gone
wherever they came from uh so so the
likelihood of an ultimate prosecution
seems pretty unlikely at this point when
contacted by global news the RCMP said
they had no further comment or update on
the investigation into the nider murder
Donna all right McKenzie gray in Ottawa
thanks a nationwide Suicide Prevention
helpline is now up and running in Canada
you can call or text 988 and be
connected to someone trained in
responding to Mental Health crisis it's
available in English and French 24 hours
a day Abigail Bean explains how it works
and why it's
needed for somebody that was so
optimistic about life and and love being
around people so much he just withdrew
and lost all hope for a better day and
and that that was devastating Jamie
huble was was just 15 and violently
bullied when he took his own life in
2011 his father Allan an Ottawa city
councelor said the family looked
everywhere for help every person in
Canada deserves access to Crisis Support
Services when and where they need it and
we are providing that Lifeline 988 The
New National Suicide helpline promising
immediate local support is now live I
truly believe it's going to make the
difference between a life lost and a
life saved conservative MP Todd dhy put
forward the motion for a three-digit
Hotline in 2020 it got unanimous consent
in the house but Thursday's launch took
nearly 3 years dhy has lost many people
to Suicide including a teenage best
friend he thinks about daily now he's in
frequent touch with the family of Carson
Cleland a boy in his writing who died by
suicide after being sexually extorted
online from the first point of contact
with this Predator to Carson's death was
12 hours
that's an hour for each year of Carson's
life so when seconds and minutes count
when we say that it truly makes a
difference this is really about reducing
those barriers that exist to people
getting help when they need help chimo
Community Services is one of the 39
organizations with trained responders
they're already getting calls on day one
it's heartening for Alan huble a staunch
mental health Advocate since Jaime's
death he want to be remembered as a
unicorn so I had a tattoo of a unicorn
that's in a j hopefully the last thing I
see in life will be that he believes 988
could have helped his family and will
help others going forward Abigail Bean
Global News
Ottawa there aren't too many events that
attract 700,000 people but the cop 28
meeting in Dubai the latest un
conference on climate change is drawing
people from all over the world with both
High Hopes And realistic expectations
Britain's King Charles is there to open
the conference he and others are
advocating for accelerating the global
transition away from fossil fuels today
delegates agreed to create a loss and
damage fund to help the world's poorest
and most vulnerable
countries
fact that we have been able to achieve
such significant milestone in the first
day of this cup is UN
presidented this is
historic the UAE and Germany both
pledged $100 million to the fund which
is intended to help poor Nations pay for
the irreversible impacts of climate
disasters well Canada has a long way to
go to reach the goal of net zero
emissions by 2050 emissions from oil and
gas and buildings continued to rise in
2022 that's according to the Canadian
climate Institute and the federal
government is facing push back on some
of its climate policies such as the
carbon tax Heather urix West has a
reality check on Canada's climate
targets it was a summer of unprecedented
displacement and loss across many parts
of Canada the impact of a warming Planet
felt with every ignition and order to
flee but experts warn summer of 2023
will pale compared to what's to come if
the world cannot lower its carbon
emissions and in Canada there is still a
a lot of work left to do we can go as
far as to say that the federal
government has um dropped the ball
according to the UN Canada still has the
widest Gap in the G20 between its words
and its actions ottawa's current climate
policies are on track to leave the
country with emission levels 27% higher
than its climate goals there's some
really big and obviously very
contentious policies that the federal
government still still needs to land
very soon namely the zero emissions
Vehicles mandate a cap on oil and gas
emissions and the clean electricity
regulation policies that have already
seen plenty of push back with the
Alberta Government threatening to set up
its own electricity entity just to defy
the proposed federal law the biggest
hurdle right now to the federal
government's climate change agenda is
the link to affordability and that's
where economists like Andrew leech agree
a has made its biggest fumble so far
when it announced a carbon tax carve out
for those that heat their homes with oil
to then um make a conception concession
in what seems like a moment of political
Panic really um undermined uh their
credibility a badly timed misstep for a
government playing catchup on its
climate goals Heather urix West Global
News
Calgary the federal government has
announced it intends to buy up to 6 16
Military surveillance planes from the
United States at a cost of more than1
billion to replace Canada's aging Fleet
of surveillance planes these aircrafts
are not just planes they are complex
weapon systems and the Poseidon is a
proven capability with a track record of
success the old plane has been in
service for almost 40 years it's
scheduled to be retired in 2030 the
defense minister says the new Boeing
Poseidon reconnaissance plane is the
only available aircraft that meets the
requirement of Canada's Air Force
they're expected to be delivered in 2026
and
27 renowned as much as he was reviled
coming up the complicated Legacy of
Henry
Kissinger there aren't too many people
who make it to 100 and even fewer who
have made a mark on the world like Henry
Kissinger did the former American
Secretary of State has died and is is
being remembered as both a towering
Diplomat and a hypocrite he steered US
foreign policy during tumultuous periods
and after he left office continued to
play a role on the world stage but his
harshest critics call him a war criminal
Eric Sorenson looks at Kissinger's
complicated
Legacy thank you nice to see you all
admired and admonished Henry Kissinger
was the architect and the face of US
foreign policy in a dangerous era his
biggest diplomatic Victory began with
secret talk with red China that led to
President Nixon's historic visit
beginning a thaw in the Cold War even as
relations cool again China's president
xiin ping today praised Kissinger's
diplomatic wisdom that helped open China
to the world he was someone in America
who understood the Chinese people the
Chinese population Kissinger's rise to
prominence was remarkable born in
Germany his family fled Nazism he served
with the US Army and Rose to become the
first foreign born US Secretary of State
there is no country in the world where
it is conceivable that a man of my
Origins could be standing here next to
the president of the United States
Kissinger was celebrated for his day
Taun with the Soviet Union and shuttled
diplomacy that paved the way for peace
between Israel and Egypt Kissinger is uh
is notable in having changed and brought
about a very different relationship that
the US had with the world Kissinger also
began secret talks to end the Vietnam
War he and North Vietnam's lead to were
awarded the Nobel Prize for Peace only
later did a recording of Kissinger
emerge on the Nixon tapes wanting to
pressure North Vietnam back to the
bargaining table I would then recommend
that you start fing the retri out them
within 48 Hours it was that Henry
Kissinger that produced an entirely
different view of the man the expanded
bombing campaign in Vietnam that spread
to Cambodia clandestine US foreign
policy also backed the military hunter
that killed political opponents in
Argentina and in Chile supported Augusto
Pinos whose military coup ousted a
democratically elected socialist
Salvador aende years later protesters
were still calling for Kissinger to be
tried for war crimes believing Millions
died from policies he directed arrest
hry Kissinger for war he said it's
always about America National Security
of course his detractors would say well
he did it in a in a very ctitious kind
of fashion and and sometimes very
morally and ethically unsound fashion
Kissinger was a larger than life figure
for a century famously saying power is
the ultimate aphrodesiac he was
complicated Jewish himself he once
suggested but for his birth he'd have
been anti-semitic yet for decades
virtually every US president called on
him for advice if I had to do it over
again I would do again substantially the
same way his legacy is polarizing to
some a great Diplomat to others a man
contemptuous of Human Rights but there
is little debate Henry Kissinger was a
man of
consequence
so-called chemical Valley ahead the
latest findings about the effect of poor
air quality on an Ontario First
Nation for decades people living in
Sarnia Ontario and the nearby om janong
First Nation have worried their
proximity to refineries and chemical
plants is making them sick the OM janong
first nation is surrounded by industry
there are dozens of large facilities
within a 25 km radius after a Global
News investigation in 2017 the Ontario
government launched a multi-million
dollar review to examine the possible
connection between air pollution from
the plants and public health last night
the results were made public and they
confirm what people feared our chief
investigative correspondent Carolyn
Jarvis has been following this story
from the
beginning it was only 6 days after
Dorothy and Wilson PL Jr's son was
diagnosed with leukemia that he was gone
six days six days
the family lives in om xinong First
Nation an area exposed to higher levels
of some air pollution including Benzene
a cancer-causing chemical is my belief
that it has something to do with it yes
years after their son's death in 2006 a
government funded Health review now
shows the level of benzene people are
breathing can cause an increase in the
risk of blood cancers leukemia with
long-term exposure the risk being the
greatest on the north side of the first
nation and in to South Sarnia close to
the chemical
plants and while the provincial
government did not release a detailed
final report an earlier project update
showed Benzene levels in that same area
estimated at up to 44 times the air
quality standard we have a right to
breathe clean air we have a right to uh
feel safe in our homes if that was found
anywhere else it would be shut down
until it's fixed the review also
indicates acid gas flaring which can
cause spikes in sulfur dioxide levels
can pose health risks to people with
breathing difficulty industry leaders
meanwhile say millions are being
invested in upgrades and they're
complying with provincial regulations
that's the focus to make sure that we're
you know playing by the rules that are
set out for us in this area others say
this review shows it's time those rules
are updated there is no excuse for these
continued high levels the air pollution
control requirements really need to be
upgraded for the facilities around Oman
and this Air Pollution Control
requirements are readily available
Ontario's environment Ministry did not
say what it's going to do with these
findings but the people of Saria and
omang say after years of waiting they
simply can't any longer Donna all right
Carolyn Jarvis
thanks next why Britain's royal family
feud is back in the
Limelight
it's no secret the relationship between
King Charles and Prince Harry is
strained a new book about the Royals
sheds light on letters reportedly
exchanged between the king and Megan
Markle in the wake of her and Prince
Harry's interview with Oprah Winfrey a
translation error in the Dutch version
of that book has reopened a wound over
allegations of Royal racism Crystal
ganing
explains in Dubai King Charles focused
on the climate crisis but a boiling
Royal Scandal dating Back 2 years has
transfixed many around the globe The
Firestorm sparked by the Dutch version
of this book endgame by omed scobby
readers for the first time saw two royal
names printed in connection with an
Infamous conversation about skin color
King Charles and Katherine Princess of
Wales in 2021 Megan Markle shocked Oprah
and the millions who watched the
interview when she revealed members of
the royal family discussed how dark
their unborn child's skin might be the
couple never revealed who was involved
in that alleged conversation and until
there is actual evidence of those
comments being made I will never believe
it but the British TV host Pierce Morgan
named the Royals on his show Wednesday
saying if Dutch readers know Brit should
know as well he's a vocal critic of
Harry and Megan the Duke and Duchess of
sun
this is what the author had to say about
the reported printing error on itvs this
morning in the UK I had never submitted
a book that had their names in it who
wrote or said what is not known there is
certainly a lot of talk about a new book
and an old Royal Scandal Crystal ganing
Global News London that's global
national for this Thursday I'm Donna FZ
and tonight's here of Canada is the
Stony Beach grain elevator near Moosejaw
Saskatchewan thanks for
[Music]
watching